[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 ce qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité
locale voici les titres de ce jeudi 12
décembre spectacle et sourire pour les
enfants malades de l'hôpital mignot
situe aux généraux concours hier le
service pédiatrie de l'établissement
fêter noël un événement assurée par
l'association rire 78 dans le cadre de
l'opération rire pour year r suite et
fin de notre dossier sur les
personnalités de l'année dans les
yvelines côté économie c'est une
entreprise saint-quentinoise qui a
marqué 2019 all three x plateforme en
ligne de vente spécialisée dans le
cyclisme
enfin la page municipal 2020 à la fin de
cette édition il est le premier candidat
officiellement déclaré à coignières et
xavier girard mènera une liste sans
étiquette et citoyenne dans la commune
qui a connu trois maires depuis 2014
et puis à suivre aussi la présentation
d'une pièce de théâtre dans ce journal
panique à l'hôtel bricoles qui est jouée
ce samedi à ablis le service pédiatrie
du centre hospitalier de versailles
situé aux chaînés rocancourt fêtait donc
noël avec enfants et familles hier un
grand spectacle avec l'association rire
soixante dix huit pour mettre des
étoiles dans les yeux de ces petits le
reportage de marie lehn iapichino pascal
assy chante pour les enfants quarante
minutes où ils essaient même participer
parce que j'essaie de transmettre ces
c'est vraiment d'être est d'être à la
maison on fait un petit spectacle à la
maison que les enfants se sentent bien
que les enfants qu que je vais remonter
sur scène se sentent à l'aise aussi il a
répondu à l'invitation de l'association
rire 78 et son opération rire pour
guérir tous les enfants suivis par le
service pédiatrie ont été conviés avec
leur famille pour ce moment festif
l'action vire pour guérir c'est pour
aller vers les publics empêchés qui
peuvent être comme ici dans un hôpital
mais également maisons de retraite ou
l'ime tous les endroits où les les
résidents n'ont pas accès à la culture
dont on leur apporte une petite bulle
comme disait pascal assy une petite
bulle de bonheur avec de la musique ou
de l'humour
voilà et parfois aussi des ateliers
c'est une manière de leur dire que l'on
se préoccupe de dans leur ensemble qu'on
a à coeur que malgré la maladie malgré
des pathologies il est une vie agréable
qu'ils aient les plaisirs de la vie
comme les autres enfants une journée
d'évasion et même de lumière pour oman
cdi pack chouette
qu'est ce que j'ai préféré me mêler d'un
fait divers au mollet les blouses roses
ont pris le relais avec une histoire de
père noël déjanté et après on a mis son
père noël et enlevant petit père noël le
spectacle comme ça pour les en france et
c'est super sympa il oublie voilà les
oublier un petit peu la maladie donc
merci à tous à une journée terminée en
beauté avec bien sûr l'arrivée du père
noël en personne qui leur a distribué
des cadeaux jusqu'à demain c'est le simi
le salon de l'immobilier d'entreprise
trois jours d'événements au palais des
congrès à paris saint quentin en
yvelines est présent sur ce rendez vous
et a reçu en plus un prix celui de
l'innovation urbaine
une récompense interdépartemental remise
par les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine
cette distinction souligne le travail du
territoire sur le déploiement numérique
dans les structures scolaires le
président de l'agglomération au micro de
michael et demi d'euros
c'est certainement en france la première
fois que 12 ville s'associent pour
transformer leur école à un niveau aussi
élevé je vous rappelle que
on améliore le plaisir d'apprendre avec
cette méthode et on améliore le plaisir
d'enseigner pour les profs et en fait on
augmente la confiance en soi des enfants
on augmente
la créativité chez les enfants et leur
autonomie le dernier focus ce soir sur
les personnalités qui ont marqué 2010 9
dans les yvelines nous avons choisi pour
la personnalité économique une
entreprise c'est en quelque sorte
l'amazone des produits cyclisme la
plateforme holt rixe a connu une année
exceptionnelle croissance continue
sponsor du tour de france est aussi
partenariat avec le groupe décathlon
d'entreprises créées en 2008 et
installée à montigny le bretonneux ne
cesse de se développer nicolas landry
pour le sujet ils ont choisi le meilleur
braquet pour leur ascension économique
avec 20% de croissance cette année all
trick signe encore de bons résultats sur
sa plateforme de e-commerce et dans ses
trois magasins cinquante mille produits
sont proposés à la vente
c'est le cas de l'établissement à
coignières ouvert depuis 2015 dans une
offre qui s'étoffe d'année en année une
clientèle qui devient de plus en plus
exigeante sur les tout derniers produits
à on arrive à avoir beaucoup de choix
on a notamment une grosse progression
sur les ventes de vélos électriques
la réussite du magasin il ya le choix et
à la technicité et donc du coup tout le
conseil qu'on peut apporter aux gens
les gens en fait tu voyais beaucoup de
produits sur notre site et du coup se
dirige vers la boutique pour avoir des
conseils on a vraiment tous types de
personnes on a vraiment de je dirais la
ménagère de plus de 50 ans qui veut se
remettre au sport et du coup qui
s'achète un vélo et rik deville aux
passionnés compétiteurs et du coup on a
une grosse aussi clientèle de club de
vélo de toute la région
hall tricks une start up créée en 2008
elle emploie plus de 150 collaborateurs
cette année l'amazone saint quentinois
du vélo a ouvert son troisième magasin à
issy les moulineaux au mois de mai puis
en septembre le géant du sport français
décathlon a racheté hall tricks une
acquisition bénéfique pour les deux
sociétés
aujourd'hui pour des quatre font ça
permet justement d'avoir un vrai
spécialiste vélo sur tout type de
produit donc aujourd'hui on n'hésite pas
à rediriger des clients soit d'un côté
soit de l'autre aujourd'hui hall tricks
et le site leader en france sur la vente
de vélos running out door en ligne et
décathlon est le leader mondial en
magasin donc c'est d'allier nos forces
peu sur le magasin pour nous apprendre à
nous développer
henri tel physique et nous aussi de
transmettre notre savoir faire
a décathlon et ensemble c'est de
proposer de meilleurs services aux
consommateurs
2010neuf c'est aussi le renforcement de
la visibilité de la marque
un spot publicitaire à chaque diffusion
des étapes du tour de france sur france
télévisions on a réussi à négocier une
visibilité forte pendant les directs
pendant la reprise transmission sur
france télévisions donc ça nous a
apporté beaucoup de retombées positives
et un surcroît de trafic sur le site
pendant la période du mois de juillet
paul tricks bascule déjà vers l'année
2020 avec des nouveaux projets des
nouveaux défis
on ouvre la vente d'occasion de vélos
d'occasion sur notre site internet
depuis quelques semaines c'est en ligne
2020 soit aussi l'international on va
continuer à développer notre présence en
dehors des frontières en se focalisant
sur l'espagne l'italie et l'allemagne
le chiffre d'affaires en 2010 neuf
devrait atteindre les 80 millions
d'euros objectif pour cette entreprise
du e-commerce maintenir le guidon dans
cette direction pour 2020
[Musique]
quelques idées de sorties à présent dans
ce journal dans moins de 15 jours c'est
noël pour beaucoup d'entre vous c'est
synonyme d'achats d'idées de cadeaux
aussi mais c'est aussi l'occasion de
multiplier les activités à vivre en
famille mélanie pokémon soir concert
pour cette chronique à loisir vous avez
choisi de fêter noël de manière décalée
ce soir vous en avez fait un avant-goût
la semaine dernière avec votre a invité
un mélo brillé mais depuis l'an dernier
la commanderie de saint quentin en
yvelines propose un noël décalé des
activités plutôt originale pour
patienter avant les fêtes ce week-end
vous pourrez notamment participé à des
ateliers de cuisine
non j'ai pas fourché charlotte blondel
professeur vous fait découvrir une
cuisine 100% végétale et surtout une
cuisine sont pour que son cru ont fait
patienter les gens ont fait patienter
les enfants aussi avant noël on a plein
de d'ateliers aussi pour l'heure pour
offrir des cadeaux pour se faire plaisir
mais différemment avec des négociations
telles que vers et green à la verrière
qui va proposer des ateliers pour
fabriquer ses propres cosmétiques une
démonstration que sa palette de nombreux
ateliers donc avec un angle original à
citer que quelques-uns paraissent que
bien sûr c'est difficile d'être
exhaustif mais on peut rajouter d'autres
création de cartes de noël connectée du
yoga en famille des décorations de noël
mathématiques en origami et l'un des
ateliers vous permet même de faire des
dessins lumineux cemaf l'eau est pas
doué qui l'animent l'artiste
plasticienne est en création la
commanderie pour cette saison l'artiste
qui nous inspire aujourd'hui est un
artiste que j'ai découvert sur les
réseaux sociaux qui à partir d'objets de
son quotidien on observant les ombres
portées de ces objets s'est mis à
dessiner tout autour et en créer une
poésie
merci mélanie est lui aussi un temps
fort en ce week-end c'est un marché
solidaire des créateurs et des
associations vous proposeront des
produits de quoi donner des idées au
père noël pour garnir garnir le pied du
sapin et aussi de nombreux marchés noël
en programmes à saint quentin en
yvelines ce week end vous en parlerai
dans votre émission le 7-8 ce loisir à
suivre après ce journal plus qu'une
pièce de théâtre et des surprises c'est
ce qui est promis par la commedia del
abily à ce samedi à la salle culturelle
l'étincelle à ablis de représentation
15h et 21h de sa création panique à
l'hôtel bricole on en parle avec pascal
vidéo bonsoir bonsoir est co créateur de
cette compagnie de théâtre vous signez
cette pièce avec corinne bidou qui est
la mise en scène et vous jouez également
dans cette pièce de la commedia del
abily déjà un mot sur cette compagnie
théâtre elle joue ses créations des
spectacles d'auteurs aussi et vous vous
jouez dans toute la france c'est ça oui
c'est ça actuellement on tourne sur
toute la france avec divers spectacles
notamment deux spectacles enfants un
sketch en format court de 30 minutes
et puis trois pièces de théâtre avec des
des genres relativement différent pour
pouvoir toucher tous les publics
le nom comédia del à bly fait tout de
suite penser à la commedia dell'arte qui
avait une vocation populaire qui est né
en italie ou au xvième siècle il ya
aucun lien on montre qu est-ce qui a une
vocation aussi populaire de votre
compagne r bien sûr mais aucun lien avec
ce qui est présenté puisque comedia
dahlab line où on a appris le nom de
comedia et puis à bly parce que voilà on
est originaire d'albi et on a voulu
mettre cette petite touche dans le nom
de notre compagnie comme du sud yvelines
alors comédia del à bly c'est le théâtre
qui vient chez vous c'est en tout cas ce
que vous promettez sur votre site
internet vous ne jouez pas qu'au théâtre
mais aussi dans des salles polyvalentes
des salles aussi de fête des salles des
fêtes
le tout en zone rurale aussi c'est ça
exactement étant donné qu'on tourne peu
sur toute la france
ben on s'adapte aux conditions alors on
va jouer aussi bien dans des salles
polyvalentes des salles des fêtes
et puis des grands théâtres comme
dernièrement la joue au théâtre
d'aurillac a joué au théâtre de
châtel-guyon voilà des décors qui
s'adapte à chaque fois oui toujours des
décors qui s'adapte et puis les décors
léger parce qu'on est une petite
compagnie donc on n'a pas beaucoup de
bras justement cette compagnie alors la
compagnie elle est composée de
aujourd'hui quatre membres donc corinne
ma femme qui s'occupe de la mise en
scène également qui a écrit cette pièce
avec moi et puis un couple
claudine et jean loup qui claudine qui
est comédienne avec nous et jean loup
qui à la régie alors on en vient à cette
pièce panique à l'hôtel bricole ce
samedi donc à les présenter à ablis une
pièce tourne et qui tourne depuis 2008
n'ont depuis six mois en france pendant
2008 j'ai c'était 2018 que j'avais la
date mais en tout cas ça fait six mois
que elle tourne en france ça fait c'est
exactement ça fait six mois qu'on a
commencé à la présenter elle prend bien
elle plaît beaucoup alors c'est une
comédie ans vient pour rire se détendre
avec des textes qui valent ce qu'ils
valent mais qu'il faut vraiment mouche à
chaque fois
mais si on fait un petit pitch c'est la
vie d'un couple d'hôteliers qui donc il
ya un hôtel dans une station thermale
qui est plutôt découragés qui réfléchit
aussi à fermer leur établissement il ya
des visiteurs des visites un peu
impromptue qui vont intervenir
exactement des visites impromptues des
contrôleurs qui viennent pour la
sécurité
enfin on touche un peu à la vie de tous
les jours pour ce couple d'hôteliers qui
qui est soumis aux contraintes
administratives et puis une clientèle
des fois un peu un peu bizarre et
inattendue actuellement le teaser de
cette pièce de théâtre à l'heure samedi
ce sont deux représentations qui sont
prévues à ablis mais pas que c'est une
soirée une journée de surprises qui qui
attendent qui attend pardon les
spectateurs oui oui on a voulu en étant
justement chez nous produire un gros
spectacle est une grosse journée de
théâtre donc on aura une présentation
avec deux présentateurs qui sont
vraiment très dynamique une première
partie puisqu'on fait venir trois trois
jeunes talents d'une compagnie du lot et
qui viennent faire leurs premières
parties
nous on jours après et puis il y aura
des surprises aussi pendant et après le
la pièce de théâtre on précise que
l'entrée sfar a se fera en participation
libre au chapeau est ce qu'il reste des
places
alors pour samedi soir la séance de 21
heures c'est complet la salle fait 336
places exactement pour 15 heures il
reste quelques places et l'entrée comme
vous dites on a décidé que pour le
théâtre pour que le théâtre soit
accessible à tous ont fait une entrée
libre au chapeau
merci pascal bidou de la commedia del
habits on rappelle un cette pièce
panique à l'hôtel bricole ce samedi à la
salle de l'étincelle ablis de
représentation à 15h et 21h merci
beaucoup merci à vous
avant la page municipal le point sur vos
conditions de circulation demain
vendredi dans les transports plusieurs
syndicats ont appelé à poursuivre la
grève contre la réforme des retraites et
jusqu au moins mardi inclus les
perturbations seront quasiment les mêmes
qu'aujourd'hui sur le trafic de la ligne
du trafic encore très partiels vous le
voyez un train par sens toutes les une à
deux heures pour la ligne e n 1 train
toutes les 30 minutes entre rambouillet
et paris-montparnasse autant de trains
sur l'axé plaisir grignon mais sur sur
des créneaux de 5h15 à 10h30 et de 16h15
à 22h donc c'est sûr les heures de
pointe 1 qu'il y aura assez train toutes
les 30 minutes pour les lignes de rer
pas de changement 1 train sur 2 en
pointe sur le rer à 1 train sur 3 sur le
rer b
enfin aucun train ne circulera encore
sur le rer c entre paris austerlitz et
les gares de versailles chantiers
versailles rive gauche et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines enfin notez
que le trafic du thé 6 reprend demain
une circulation à quasi-normal notamment
sur des villes comme vélizy et viroflay
[Musique]
la fin de cette édition dédiée aux
élections municipales scrutin au
programme les 15 et 22 mars prochain
cette information est désormais
officielle aux mureaux le maire divers
gauche françois garay ce sera bien
candidat pour un quatrième mandat en cas
de nouvelles élections ce sera le
dernier a affirmé l'élu de 70 ans
françois garay souhaite impulser
continuer de grands projets le plan au
coeur de ville arrivée du rer e eole est
également rénovation la rénovation
urbaine face à lui il y aura notamment
hervé riou président du cirque
aquasports qui conduira une liste sans
étiquette l'union des démocrates
musulmans français a également prévu
d'investir un candidat dans la ville
elle aussi est maire sortante mais dans
la commune de saint cyr l'école sonia
breux a lancé officiellement à sa
candidature hier mercredi les lui a
succédé en février à bernard de bain
dans la ville yvelinoise mathilde et
demi avec sa liste saint cyr au coeur
2020 sonia bros lance sa campagne pour
les municipales 2020 la proximité et les
changes avec les nouveaux habitants
c'est ce que veut la mer pour sa liste
divers droite on a passé les deux
derniers mandats
construire les équipements qui était
nécessaire pour accueillir une nouvelle
population
cette nouvelle population elle nous a
été imposée à la fois par la dent si la
demande de densification de l'état sur
les buts 2e couronne et la vente des
terrains de l'état sur la zac charles
renard les habitants de saint cyr sont
venus soutenir leur maire tout en
espérant que son programme répondent à
la demande des nouveaux arrivants de la
ville sûre qu'elles soient à l'écouté
des saint cyriens qu'elle propose des
innovations dans la vie quotidienne
dans les rapports et des services
publics avec l'urbanisme avec la
circulation avec le cadre de vie donc on
attend vraiment
tous à 2 pour sony à broc qui occupe la
mairie depuis le début de l'année sans
cire doit se développer pour devenir une
ville touristique et non une ville de
transition entre foyers et travail j'ai
envie qu'on ait du commerce de proximité
j'ai envie qu'on ait envie de se balader
dans nos rues qu'on ait envie d'aller
admirer nos sites historiques puisque
saint cyr et quand même on porte de
versailles
et à quand même de gros atouts et la
maire sortante est pour l'instant face à
la liste saint cyr l'école en commun qui
n'a pas encore de têtes de liste
désignées à coignières qui a connu trois
maires depuis 2014 à une élection
municipale partielle qui a installé
didier fischer comme mère il ya un an la
campagne du scrutin se lancent peu à peu
premiers candidats officiellement
déclarés c'est xavier girard bonfort
bonsoir alors vous êtes trésorier du
comité des fêtes de la commune vous
conduirait la liste sans étiquette
coignières à venir c'est une association
d'habitants à la base un qui a été créée
en 2018 au moment de l'opposition sur le
projet de fusion avec mort pas pourquoi
créer cette association à l'épaule au
départ c'était vraiment un collectif de
citoyens qui qui étaient horrifiés de ce
qui est arrivé à leur ville leur village
vous avez touché à leurs valeurs et là à
ce moment là on a créé ce collectif qui
était l'union de tous les démocrates et
tous les républicains
pour nous c'était une infamie de revenir
sur nos repas en tout cas de faire cette
union sans nous concerter et un projet
qui a été ensuite abandonnés du coup
c'était là juste suite de proposer cette
liste là pour ces élections municipales
valaisan c'est tout à fait ça j'en fais
partie donc beaucoup de policiers d'un
secousse a résonné notre notre devoir de
faire quelque chose en fait ça a
réveillé le citoyen qui était en nous et
se dire que
on pouvait pas se laisser maniées par
des politiques il se passait des choses
en derrière nous on ne comprenait pas
tout et on a envie d'agir voilà alors qu
on ira bien qu'il ya la volonté d'être
apolitique ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas
de revendication d'investiture ça ça va
rassembler diverses sensibilités cette
liste on essaye d'aller au plus large de
la droite de la gauche les écologistes
une seule ce critère qui a ramé diable
on ne veut pas d'extrême voilà donc on
peut être encarté on peut être encarté
il ya plusieurs personnes qui sont à
différents partis qui sont engagés
politiquement depuis plusieurs années
parfois c1 constitue pas un problème
c'est juste la diversité on veut que
toutes ces différences face est
différent c'est notre seconde donc voilà
on parlait du projet de fusion qui a été
avorté on rappelle qui a entraîné une
large défection de la majorité à
l'époque et est conduit à la démission
de jean-pierre sevestre en septembre
2010 8,3 mer en six ans à coignières une
année 2018 finalement mouvementée est ce
que depuis l'élection de didier fischer
d'une certaine sérénité qui revenue dans
cette commune on le rappelle moindre
4500 habitants
est ce que c'est c'est votre avis et ça
a été très difficile pendant quatre ans
avec tous des projets quand est bloqué
donc qui ont avorté qui ont été
reportées pour certains donc là
effectivement d'avoir un maire depuis un
an avec une équipe municipale
ça apporte en plus c'est certain que ça
ne change depuis les deux trois
dernières années maintenant certaine
sérénité oui retrouver c'est pas pour
autant qu'il faut rester vigilant et on
est dans le challenge de l'équipe de
monsieur fisher est ce que la création
par exemple de conseils de quartier qui
a été une initiative du maire actuel
indiqué fisher est ce que c'est une
série qui va dans la bonne voie vous qui
prônez justement une liste citoyenne est
ce que les le citoyen doit avoir son mot
à dire dans la décision politique d'une
commune on parlait enfin en colis tous
les deux et puis avec ma colistière qui
était avec moi petit monde on a
participé à ces comités de quartier ça
ça revient d'une bonne décision on pense
de l'équipe en place
après je les 10 en fin de conseil
municipal monsieur fisher
personnellement j'étais un petit peu
frustré des suites puisque en fin de
compte ce qui revient principalement
c'est des problèmes de voirie des
problèmes d'éclairage des problèmes de
propreté
la plupart sont retrouvés dans le
périmètre de la sky et on n'a pas de
visibilité quant aux suites d sinon
davantage à améliorer en tout cas cessé
sur la codification effectivement des
suites à donner mais en tout cas oui au
départ ça vient démocratie participative
avec les citoyens plutôt en plus c'était
plutôt bien géré avec des grosses
participations
attention on parle de votre programme il
reposera sur quatre piliers la famille
d'abord comment comptez vous agir sur ce
sujet de la famille à la famille on va
reprendre surtout aussi de
l'intergénérationnel on va reprendre de
la petite enfance à la séniorité on
pense créer certaines choses comme la
pass mobilité pour un handicap également
pour les jeunes enfants c'est compliqué
d'avoir une poussette traversée
traversée coignières actuellement on a
des trottoirs qui sont qui sont
défoncées c'est une certaine dangerosité
également on pense également créé un
site il ainsi tea party était déjà dans
le programme de l'année dernière un
skate park
un nouvel espace de jeu dans la
résidence où il n'y en a pas voilà un
certain nombre de choses comme ça
évidemment avec la participation des
enfants aussi en résidence des personnes
âgées
on a beaucoup d'idées dans domaine un
volet environnement aussi est ce que
vous êtes favorable à ces demandes de la
munition municipalité d'intégrer le parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse coignières pourrait l'intégrer
et ce dès 2023 comme ville porte c'est à
dire un statut de villes membres
finalement se classer une première c'est
une première étape vers l'intégration
totale
il faut aller en ce sens il faut faire
partie du pnr pourquoi n'y a je pense
qu'il faut partir fois reparti du pnr
comme ville porte va être compliqué
d'aller plus loin puisque on a quand
même une énorme zone commerciale et
industrielle et puis la fameuse
nationale 10 qui le coupe en deux
instants mais entre saint-rémy l'honorer
le mesnil saint denis qui font partie du
pnr on se trouve là entre deux et on a
des très très beaux espaces qui sont les
bois dit dassault on a le
tant duval favery on a des gens qui sont
maintenant tous bio donc on a notre
place au sein du pnr un volet sécurité
aussi alors la majorité actuelle est
revenu sur la police intercommunale qui
avait été créée sous la majorité de jean
pierre sauvestre une police
intercommunale avec maurepas et est-ce
que c'était une mauvaise décision est ce
qu'il fallait la conserver cette police
intercommunale
je vous dirais qu'au départ je trouvais
que c'était une bonne décision
le fait qu'on a une police
intercommunale parce que ça permettait
de mutualiser les moyens
donc les notamment avec une présence le
samedi maintenant qu'on a une police qui
est revenu dans notre giron
on a des plannings évidemment plus
étroit la municipalité actuelle a voulu
se doter d'une police plus importantes
ont passé de cette fonctionnaire à douze
fonctionnaires en tout cas sûr si on a
été effectif
ça peut permettre de faire des choses
intéressantes maintenant c'est pas
encore réellement en place
on n'a pas encore les effectifs on n'a
pas encore de retour mais par contre oui
effectivement
le fait d'avoir deux fonctionnaires ça
permettrait de faire des actions
pédagogiques n'est pas que de la
répression
et ça pourrait être intéressant il idem
pour les pompiers
on a deux pompiers dans la vie s'ils
sont assez connus là dessus pour leur
action on pourrait faire des actions
notamment au sein des écoles enfin le
dernier volet c'est l'économie coignard
et et fait également de zones
commerciales les portes de chevreuse
forum gibet et par ios 5 est limitrophe
qui est sûre située sur la commune de
maurepas saint quentin en yvelines a
lancé une réflexion autour de cette zone
commerciale vieillissante
est ce qu'il faut aller en ce sens si ce
qu'il faut réfléchir à une nouvelle
stratégie pour cette zone commerciale
c'est connu de tout le monde sait que le
modèle actuel
arrive enfin le modèle commercial
accueille lille arrive en fin de vie
donc on a des grands espaces qui vont
petit à petit est des friches
ça commence déjà donc il faudra adapter
l'ensemble des espaces et notamment il
n'y a pas que ça il ya également les
petits commerces constitue un vrai souci
sur coignard on a beaucoup de grandes
surfaces
on a trois gros porteurs d'ailleurs qui
se porte pas très bien et on a besoin
d'un espace commerce au sein du village
donc quand on pense également à créer au
coeur du village un espace qui permet de
redynamiser le village qui commence est
un peu vieillissant avec une résidence
des résidences qui sont nés entre les
années 80-90 sur ce sujet par exemple
des zones commerciales ça implique un
travail forcément avec l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines il est ce
qu'il faut renforcer les liens avec
l'agglomération quelle est votre
position c'est juste et nécessaire
clairement ils ont vraiment les cartes
en main comme vous savez dans une
commune plus de 50% on revient
maintenant de pirae m la communauté
d'agglo et ses surfaces commerciales vu
la surface que ça représente un corner
c'est juste nécessaire indispensable de
travailler avec les instances de rails
sur des sujets comme le carrefour de la
malmö douanier unique à de concertation
publique qui est en cours actuellement
peut être aussi sur une requalification
de la nationale 10 on sait que le maire
actuel souhaiterait un enfouissement
comme c'est en projet à trappes il faut
travailler sur ce genre de projet alors
pour amal me donne alors le plaisir d'y
aller tout à l'heure pour pour la reine
une clôture
effectivement il faut redéfinir la
nationale 10 en tant que tel à lui coupe
la ville en deux il ya un gros projet
sur le quartier de la guerre une
redéfinition ça peut être l'objet de le
faire un iphone ou un enfouissement et
puis le fait de faire des voies
pédestres ou cyclistes nous permettent
d'aller d'un quartier à l'autre
effectivement un dernier mot il nous
reste à peu près 20 secondes les
derniers les prochains part dans les
prochains rendez vous est ce que vous
avez des rendez-vous réunion publique
aux environs en faire deux ateliers
participatifs 6 en août m on a déjà
cerné un certain nombre d'idées on va
les challenges et vis-à-vis des citoyens
et puis effectivement des réunions
publiques mois de mars avant les
élections j'ai prévu merci à xavier
girard tête de liste de coignières à
venir et je précise que vous êtes donc
le premier candidat déclaré
officiellement dans cette commune où le
maire sortant didier fischer devrait
être également en lice pour un nouveau
mandat voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi belle soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]